[Music]
on this Friday night the weather outside
is downright frightful brutal conditions
are battering parts of North America
stay home and ruining travel plans how
long this extreme weather could last
shooting spree in Paris a suspected hate
crime he accused other women with the
law and the anger of police Rising
anxiety over China's Rising coveted
cases the potential Ripple effects for
Canada's strained Health Care system
plus one family's unbreakable those
bombs there they have to be around 100
or maybe probably better than 100 years
old decoration tradition
global national with Fara Nasser
[Music]
a Relentless storm bearing down on both
eastern and western Canada today
bringing with it wind snow freezing rain
and power outages to hundreds of
thousands of Canadian homes
and then the travel piece there's a good
chance the family members flying in for
Christmas dinner won't make it boards
filled with bad news arrivals and
departures of all the flights scheduled
to fly out of Vancouver today 78 have
been canceled so far in Toronto more
than 185 in Ottawa 31 and further east
in Montreal 29. That's not including the
dozens and dozens of delays
good evening and thank you for joining
us from hopefully a place that's warm
and safe now is just about the time many
Canadians are wondering whether to keep
or cancel Christmas plans with power
problems messy roads and Bone chilling
colds it isn't exactly the perfect
Christmas holiday picture many
envisioned months ago Mike drolet now
with the most populated places in Canada
impacted
storm hit Toronto with a ferocity unseen
in perhaps ever 10 to 15 foot waves hit
the shore but with 100 kilometer per
hour winds expected through the evening
they could top 30 feet across all five
Great Lakes foreign
temperatures on Thursday night continued
into Friday morning and then fell off a
cliff dropping from plus three degrees
at 9am to minus nine three hours later
turning water on the roads into an icy
mess parts of the 401 highway were
closed as the opp reported hundreds of
accidents
visibility deteriorated so rapidly
border crossings from Ontario to the U.S
had to be closed leading to Toronto's
mayor reiterating what environment
Canada had earlier suggested the best
thing probably that you can do over the
next day or two or three is to stay home
and that's good advice for those already
home or at their destination less so for
the thousands of Travelers stuck in
airports like Alex desier and her
friends in Montreal they expected and
planned for delays so they brought an
air mattress to the terminal I think
Comfort is not a choice it's an option
that you need to choice right so we're
here with eating and then actually
having a good time nearby the lineup for
the white rebooking phones was long and
barely moving I'm not one that easily
gives up so uh but I don't know I've got
my husband waiting in the car delays and
cancellations primarily impacted those
flying towards Vancouver WestJet
canceled all flights in and out of
Ontario in BC Air Canada followed with
cancellations of its own leaving
Travelers grumbling the airlines aren't
super great to deal with they haven't
been super polite
in PC the storm continues to confound
with overwhelming amounts of snow in
Coquitlam and a mix of freezing rain and
snow creating the possibility of falling
ice or ice bombs on the port man and
Alex Fraser Bridges both had to be
closed for safety issues but with all
the warnings from government the impacts
were little as most people chose to stay
home micro like Global News Toronto
in the U.S the storm has been deadly
officials have confirmed at least three
weather-related deaths today with fears
there could be more coming more than 200
million Americans are under some kind of
weather warning and as Jennifer Johnson
reports Millions have been left without
power there
hurricane-like winds Arctic air and what
meteorologists call a bomb Cyclone are
creating pre-Christmas travel chaos from
Texas to the U.S Canadian border
thousands of flights have been canceled
Chicago and Denver two of the largest
travel hubs are among the hardest hit
airports stranding and rerouting
passengers there's literally just people
sleeping all I mean in our terminal all
over the place I have this insane
itinerary now it's been a little
nerve-wracking nerves are also frayed
for those on trains highways and Roads
Amtrak has canceled service on more than
20 routes most in the midwest near zero
visibility is shut down highways between
Colorado and Wyoming even cities in the
South like Nashville Tennessee and
Jackson Mississippi have been crippled
by snow seasoned winter drivers are
taking no chances like even in the areas
that have been plowed really well if you
get above 40 miles an hour you start
sliding around but it's the record cold
temperatures that have officials most
concerned Denver's International Airport
saw a 37 degree drop in 10 temperature
in one hour the biggest ever recorded I
think our plans are ruined parts of
Wyoming could hit minus 56 degrees
frigid temperatures in Texas have
already caused power outages leaving
some residents in the cold and dark the
governor promises the power grid will
hold up after it crashed last winter
resulting in at least 250 deaths I'm
really glad that I have a fireplace
because otherwise I'd be freezing right
now Georgia has declared a state of
emergency Atlanta is expected to record
its coldest Christmas Eve on record in
cities across the country homeless
shelters are packed Governors are
begging residents to stay home
stay inside stay off the roads the last
second shopping is not worth it if it
would cost you your life but millions of
Americans are still traveling trying
desperately to get to their loved ones
the joy of Christmas looking more like a
nightmare I was freaked out because I've
never been in like a blizzard or like
snow or any weather like out before 44
of America's 48 lower states are under
some kind of winter wind chill freeze or
high wind alert a brutal not so very
Merry Christmas weekend for Millions
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
so clearly some major damage already
done across large swaths of Canada in
the U.S but how long is this extreme
weather going to last and could there be
more disruptions ahead our Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell joins us
now Anthony we're all focused on the
next couple of days is this going to be
the worst of it well far across the
country as a whole I would say the worst
conditions are occurring right now both
systems the one on the west coast and
this monster here in Ontario and Quebec
will begin weakening come tomorrow in
between that frigid Arctic air also
starting to moderate and it'll become
well above average through the Prairies
into early next week but we have a ways
to go and this spin you see right here
that is a bomb Cyclone that's now pushed
into Quebec we've got rain for much of
the maritime some snow to the north
blizzard conditions and a hundred
kilometer per hour winds back on the
other side of this low and that's going
to continue even in to Saturday around
the Great Lakes blizzard warnings in
place here for your red areas travel not
recommended Northern Ontario as well
still some extreme cold warnings and
still some freezing rain issues on the
west coast but hang in there it gets
better by Christmas and the warming
Trend continues through next week pharah
okay that's some good news thank you
gold news meteorologist Anthony Farnell
to Paris now where a gunman opened fire
at a Kurdish Cafe and Community Center
in a bustling neighborhood in the city
three people are dead and police are
trying to determine if it was a targeted
attack the suspect who's being arrested
was awaiting trial for a separate
violent incident at a migrant Camp
Kurdish community members say they have
reported threats to police in the past
and as Crystal gamensing Reports
frustrations have now reached a boiling
point with a riot breaking out near the
crime scene
people originally gathering in
solidarity following a deadly shooting
found themselves swept up in a mob
attack
projectiles were tossed at police in the
10th District of Paris in response
officers fired tear gas
eventually Riot police moved in to
disperse the crowd from the typically
busy Multicultural area filled with
shops bars and restaurants
I'm a defense lawyer it's my job to
defend people who are losing it for
different reasons at different times but
I am in shock and I am grieving
[Music]
69 year old French man was arrested by
police accused of murder and attempted
murder a construction worker in the area
who witnessed the incident told the
Associated Press that the shooter had a
small pistol was silent and appeared
calm the individual in question was
already known to the judicial Services
his name appeared in two cases officials
say the accused was not labeled an
extremist by government agencies the
incident unfolded at a Turkish Cultural
Center run by the Kurdish Democratic
Council its leadership is calling the
shooting an act of Terror saying it
followed threats from Turkey before the
riots broke out the interior Minister
took in the sight of the investigation
and spoke with reporters on the scene
about enhancing security
I asked all police services in Paris and
elsewhere in the national territory to
protect the places where the Kurdish
Community Gathers as well as Turkish
diplomatic locations
president Emmanuel macron said the
Kurdish people in the capital had been
the target of a heinous attack he also
praised law enforcement for their
courage and composure
Crystal gemancing Global News London
after an historic surprise visit to the
U.S to keep up crucial support for his
country Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is back to work in Kiev
foreign
Victory zelinski says in this short
video as Ukraine approaches its second
year of enduring Russia's brutal
invasion of the country Washington is
already sending some Goodwill after his
trip today the U.S Congress approved a
more than 44 billion dollar U.S Aid
package announced earlier this week to
further support Ukraine's defenses
in Washington the January 6 committee
has released its final report and it
points its finger directly at one person
former president Donald Trump the more
than 800-page final document alleges
Trump engaged in a multi-par conspiracy
to overturn the 2020 election he lost
the report released by the Congressional
panel investigating last year's attack
on the U.S Capitol concluded Trump was
the central cause of the events it
suggests 11 recommendations to ensure
nothing like this happens again
including a change to the nation's
Insurrection laws that would effectively
bar Donald Trump from ever holding
public office again
covet is resurging with a Vengeance in
China
scientists fear could happen next
plus the money earmarked to upgrade
Canada's Search and Rescue helicopters
Ottawa has announced two contracts to
extend the life of Canada's Fleet of
Search and Rescue helicopters
the Cormorant helicopters which have
flown search and rescue missions since
2001 now require upgrades to remain
operationally effective the Department
of National Defense says it'll spend
1.24 billion dollars for those updates
that will involve contracts awarded to
companies CAE in Montreal and Leonardo
UK and Britain to perform the overhaul
it will also add three more helicopters
to the 13 now in the fleet
this holiday season marks the first
without coveted restrictions for many
Canadians since the pandemic began but
that hasn't stopped lingering concern
about the virus and now they're scoring
anxiety over an explosion of cases in
China which some scientists warn will
become a petri dish for new variants of
the virus to emerge and that's raising
worries already for our overstretched
health care System here at home tariya
isri reports
for most Canadians this is the first
restriction free Christmas since the
pandemic but Canada's top doctor is
warning covid-19 could still unleash new
problems overall the virus is still
young in terms of his circulation in the
human population even though we're fed
up with it in her year-end interview
with global news Dr Teresa Tam urged
Canadians to take precautions with
covid-19 RSV and the flu all circulating
at high levels we can write our own
story as to what happens post-holiday
season if we took these measures we will
come out of this next weeks the next
couple of weeks
um and and more safely but with
hospitals overwhelmed healthcare workers
on the front line are frustrated saying
the federal government's messaging does
not go far enough this is the first uh
you know Christmas holiday period where
we've gone into it buck naked in terms
of any public health policies Omicron
arrived around this time last year and
spread rapidly over the holidays and the
months that followed since then it's
become the dominant strain and there are
fears about new strains with covid-19
cases exploding in China Beijing backed
away from its zero coveted policy after
unprecedented protests since then cases
have swelled in a population with little
immunity whenever
versus
spreading anywhere
any with potential for variants to
emerge modeling by a British research
firm shows China is dealing with a
million new coveted cases daily and is
expected to be the world's biggest
outbreak it's likely that those numbers
will not be officially given by the
Chinese government if you have an
explosion of cases in other countries
whether it be China the U.S or anywhere
in the world that's going to have an
impact here so doctors are urging people
wherever they travel whether it's
between countries or between households
to remember the pandemic is not over
teria Israeli Global News
Ottawa
it's all about trust ahead a status
update on how Canadians feel about
social media
the pandemic has changed so many things
about our world and how we see it and it
appears to have had an unexpected impact
on social media a new ipsos poll
conducted for Global News found nearly a
third of Canadians say they are less
likely to trust what they read on social
media than they were prior to the
pandemic as Mike Armstrong explains the
poll also shows some significant
generational divides
for all Canadians are basically split on
social media 54 say they trust the
information they get and 46 percent say
they don't where it gets interesting is
how it breaks down by age the younger
the group The more trusting more than
two-thirds of gen Z say they trust
information on social media
significantly less for Millennials and
Gen X it's only about half and for Baby
Boomers only 45 percent trust social
media information older Generations
receive much more concerned about social
media's ability to spread false
information quickly
now the big difference may be confidence
older Canadians grew up with traditional
media where information was usually fact
checked before being put out to the
world while younger Generations have
grown up knowing what they read online
isn't necessarily the truth in social
media you have to be your own editor and
I think younger people are much more uh
attuned to that
okay the vast majority of Canadians
believe misinformation is a problem 79
say it threatens Democratic Values but
again different age groups disagree on
what to do should there be regulation of
social media to cut down on fake news or
should it be left up to the platforms to
police themselves overall 8 in 10
Canadians say stronger regulation is
needed but younger Generations are more
likely to feel things should be left as
is the younger people are saying I got
this I could I can do this on my own I
don't need you regulating it for me a
service that is broadly as broadly
inclusive as possible the ipsos poll
also looked at Elon musk's takeover of
Twitter the company's reputation has
taken a hit with Canadians 61 percent
say musk's purchase means misinformation
is more likely to spread
my Grumps from Global News Montreal
[Music]
next the festive federal government
video raising some eyebrows
Omar
it's time
and with the word of prime minister
Justin Trudeau transfer Minister Omar
gabra has permitted Santa to use
Canadian airspace this holiday season
the more than two minute long video
showed earlier today to the minister of
social media channels online have people
divided on whether it's a fun spoof
Mission Impossible style or if it just
costs taxpayers too much money to
produce
around this time of year we can get
caught up in all things new and shiny
well one New Brunswick couple is
certainly going for Sparkle but they're
Christmas trees ornaments are more than
a hundred years old our Shelly Steves
spoke with them
I'm old-fashioned so I keep my tree the
same I love it and he he's so excited
like super excited
streets there's roughly rate around 400
ornaments on it
there is approximately what maybe 2 900
mini lights on it Dad gave me probably
most of the old ornaments so they've
been on our tree now for 51 years those
bombs there they have to be around 100
or maybe probably better than 100 years
old even the tops are arrested on them
there's one here the pink one those have
been on my tree as long as I can
remember I believe he bought them
perhaps maybe back in the late 50s their
prices I wouldn't sell them for any
amount of money I'll sit by myself and
look just keep staring at the ornaments
and every ornament when you look at it
you think of all the Christmases you had
when you were little this one huh oh
yeah that's one of me I was about 11 or
12 years old me and my dad and on this
tree you can pick out a lot of the
ornaments I believe that's the pink one
right there there's always been on my
tree as long as I remember and the kids
always they always look for that pink
bow aren't you scared
to drink some I've had it for 51 years
that tree and I've never broken a norm
in 51 years I hear that you're not
allowed to touch the bulbs I'm not
allowed to touch the bulbs put them on
the tree put them away nothing I don't
let anybody else do it except me but
sometimes it's hard to get them to hang
just right
sometimes you end up putting one at a
time right then I had to sit down for a
while I'm 73. uh I wouldn't tell you her
age
everybody laughs at me but at Christmas
time once I get the tree up and the
icicles on I hide the remote I put it on
the cover nobody can get a hook well
yeah all the icicle was all for oh
everybody laughs at that anything ever
happened to house catch a fire ornaments
go first
what about Joe yeah
you think somebody in your family will
take on the tradition we're hoping
oh that is just a great way to end the
newscast that is global national for
this Friday night I'm Farah Nasser and
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us and I just want to
give a special thanks to our field Crews
tonight who Brave the elements much more
than usual to bring us the news before
we go we have one more festive tree to
show you this one at the Valley Zoo in
Edmonton we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com calling
Christy will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow that's it from me until the New
Year wishing you a safe happy and
peaceful holiday season good night
[Music]
thank you